[Music]
Aubrey thanks for being here you look
gorgeous thank you you um it's funny we
have something you started in the
business at NBC you started as an NBC
page that's right yes I was a terrible
page
um are you really were you a bad page
yeah I was actually a page at your show
a couple of times yeah I I gave tours in
your studio
and I would lie about you and
uh you're being honest you would tell
lies because a lot of the pages I
overheard them sometimes and they would
clearly kind of make stuff up sometimes
yeah I would I was one of those people
um
that was me what did you say I don't
know I can't remember I would just be
like and now we're in Studio Six hey a b
uh C or whatever and I go this is the
home to Conan O'Brien he's a terrible
monster truck a violent man you see him
run
um you'd say that to me and people just
be like oh yeah we've heard that yeah
yeah that story before no I didn't I
didn't say that I did like makeup stuff
a lot but right did you like did you
like being a page did you enjoy it
um I liked it I wasn't I I don't think I
was like the the the right type I didn't
have like the right attitude I wasn't
like a chipper um page
um I was kind of I'm picking up on that
right now yeah
um but I liked it in my own way I was
kind of like a weird dark witchy page in
the corner
that's so fizzy ring the blue code and
the nice NBC logo and the pins and
everything but you were you were
smoldering yeah but people loved me my
tours loved me oh good yeah well that's
important yeah well you've done so well
I mean just a couple years ago your page
and now you are uh co-starring Parks and
Recreation you guys are nominated for an
Emmy for best comedy show
congratulations yep that's got to feel
good are you good now have you
I'm assuming you're going to the Emmys
is that right
um yes I am actually I'm really excited
it's like the first I went once before
um with someone else but this is the
first time that I deserve to go
[Laughter]
uh so what was it okay though the
previous time uh that you went did you
walk the red carpet
um yes I did I actually walked uh I
walked one red carpet with uh one of my
film Idols Sharon Stone totally by
accident she kind of like took me under
her wing and then uh and kind of gave me
some pointers and what pointers did
Sharon Stone give you she she kind of
called me out on my own a little
bit because I kind of I don't smile that
much and I'm kind of like it's I'm not
like a smiley person and and she kept
telling me uh she kept like kind of
whispering to my ear like if you want to
be a movie star you better smile and be
Sunny
she's like give them what they want did
she talk to you about swearing a lot on
television
sorry that doesn't matter though he'll
bleep that she told me not to um not to
chew on my hair because people will
think I'm a lesbian
did she really say that yeah
um
what about chewing on other people yeah
Andy
curious
I mean what did Sharon say about it I'm
going to listen to her for sure yeah
yeah she's cool yeah Sharon Stone now so
what's your strategy you're going to go
on the red carpet this year that's an
intense environment what do you what's
your strategy how are you going to go
I'm just gonna
get as drunk as I can and deny deny deny
what are they going to be accusing you
of oh you'll see I did not wait what are
we talking about oh who knows uh do you
say chimpanzee or chimpanzee
Fork